[Music]
hello everybody my name is Thomas
Johnson I received my PhD at UCL in 2019
and since then I've been uh a postto and
then an independent fellow since 2021
performing research within the UCL
Department of biochemical engineering
and in this confence presentation today
I'm going to be describing how at UCL
we've been applying the state-of-the-art
most advanced 3D imaging techniques in
order to visualize and characterize a
wide range of Downstream bioprocessing
structures to better relate their
structure with function and performance
and how we can then start to use this
information in order to inform the
design of new geometries of the
future I'm going to give an example of a
collaboration with Dr Simone de Martino
from the University of Edinburgh and all
of this work has been performed with
Professor Dan bracewell in UCL and
alongside uh Dan braell and Dr kazim
rafik we run the UCL Pool Center of
Excellence which is a multi-million
dollar um system whereby we have set up
a wide range of projects both in
upstream and downstream bioprocessing
that's allowed us to perform research
with pool Corporation who are a leading
vendor in the space we currently got
over 10 PhD projects two posts and also
myself in a fellowship role and this
what this allows me to do is collaborate
and and perform experiments with all of
these projects and also to support them
in their own research I can also then
interact with the uh sponsor company po
Corporation itself as well and through
some further NXT funding I've been able
to set up some other collaborations both
internal to UCL and also externally and
at the end of this presentation I'll be
going through a case study we recently
submitted for publication
with the University of
Edinburgh and so I'm going to start off
by talking about why we wanted to use
these high resolution imaging techniques
and particularly focusing on Downstream
bioprocessing structures before talking
about how um the some of these
techniques have been used and how they
complement each
other I'll then speak about how we've
been applying this to various case
studies before um talking about how
we've been applying this in a uh case
study for 3D printing new materials
before making some conclusions and where
we're going with this in the future now
it's very important to state that all of
this research goes across multiple
length scales so we're considering an
entire capsule or an entire
chromatography column down to the
individual nanop pole within these
structures and everything in
between so everybody familiar with bioo
processing in recent years will be well
aware that we're not just speaking about
monoco antibodies in terms of being the
golden standard for biologics anymore is
very much a wide range of different
products for example leirus aav uh liid
nanoparticles and liposomes that provide
a lot of therapeutic advantages and
opportunities in the medical space to
come up with new treatments and we've
seen that a lot with the vaccines and
also Gene therapies of the present and
future however these new exciting
products also present substantial
challenges during our our medicine
manufacturing and we've particularly
focused on the downstream processing
here so what we wanted to do is really
go back to basics and understand how
does the structure of a chromatography
column or any other Downstream
bioprocessing material relate to its
function and performance how can then we
start to uh specifically tailor this to
these new and exciting products of
interest that are coming into the
market so in order in order to perform
high resolution 3D imaging we've applied
three main techniques alongside various
others and we're going to describe those
now the first and the real main
technique we've used in this approach is
x-ray computed tomography or CT for
short which is very similar to cat
scanning that you may have had at
hospital whereby we take thousands of
images of a sample and we can then
reconstruct that into a 3D Volume so on
the bottom left hand corner we've got a
2d raadio graph of a chromatography
column
and then just next to it if we want to
perform nanotomography and at UCL when
we got this piece of equipment in 2016
we were very state-ofthe-art in terms of
the technology we had we were then
wanted to look inside these small
structures requiring very small samples
so what I had to do is manually um
adhere samples in this case sperical
chromatography bead on top of a pin head
which which is very challenging to say
the least but allows us to achieve
nanoscale
resolutions this technique is extremely
effective and also versatile however if
we want even better resolution than what
we can get through x-ray CT we then
applied Focus iron beam microscopy very
similar to scanning electr microscopy
however what we can then do with an
additional focused iron beam is cut
through the material and then by taking
images of the material that we've cut
through and then sequentially performing
slice and view we can then get sub
nanoscale resolutions uh for these
samples and really resolve all of the
finest features however I have to say
this technique is destructive to the
sample and it's highly intensive in
terms of sample preparation
requirements both of these techniques
are fantastic for looking at the
structure of these materials in terms of
their detailed por geometry however they
do struggle somewhat when we start to
look at samples of biological material
and fance within them therefore the
third technique in our suite is confocal
microscopy and this is perfect for this
whereby we can di or tag a product or
impurity of interest and after our
processing we can then use conf focal
microscopy in order to visualize where
the material is retained within our
samples so by complementing these
techniques together we get a huge amount
of information that we wouldn't be able
to achieve just using one
approach now I'm going to speak about
some of the case studies and published
work that we've looked at in terms of
visualizing and characterizing
downstream bioprocessing materials and I
want you to start with chromatography in
this case because it's really the work
course of Downstream bioprocessing it's
very ubiquitous in lots of biologic
manufacturing processes whereby you've
effectively got a cylinder which is
comprises of tightly packed spherical
chromatography beads and using x-ray CT
we were able to actually look inside
this material without having to cut it
open and this allowed us to challenge
lots of the pre-existing uh Concepts and
and assumptions that we make about
chromatography for example HP or height
equivalent theoretical plates is
something that builds on a lot of
assumptions that all of your
chromatography beads are the same size
the same shape they will sit nicely in
rows and columns and even though we
didn't know we KN everybody knew that
this wasn't necessarily the case in
reality um by using x-ray CT we're
really able to see inside of this
material so you can see on the left hand
side we've got a cut through of of a one
M prepack column then hopefully you can
see the whole cylinder you've got these
individual particles which we can then
uh zoom in further and then see all of
these individual beads and again you can
see they're not all of the same size
they're not all sitting in a nice Row in
this in this
image by Building Up 3D data sets not
just 2D information is presented on the
left hand side we're able to then
perform positional based analysis on
these materials and something we were
particularly interested in is was
looking at the interparticle
parity and something that's well known
again is wall effects whereby you have a
difference in pack in density at the
edge of the column compared to the
center and by performing x-ray CT and
then analyzing these structures we're
able to verify that we could um see a
difference in interbed paracity uh at
the edge of a column shown on the white
bars compared to the Center for a range
of different commercially available
resins something I'm not going to show
in these slides but is very important is
that we're always comparing the values
that we're obtaining from our images to
literature and also performing
orthagonal techniques to verify that
what we're seeing in our images can be
considered representative for example if
you're looking into bity dexon blue
pulse will give you that information if
you run on the
actor so we looked at various resins and
then we wanted to see what they looks
like inside of those materials and so by
applying nanotomography at UCL at the
electrochemical Innovation laboratory
and the department of chemical
engineering we're able to look at three
different types of resin aggro so and
ceramic in a similar manner to what we
saw for the columns and again you can
see on the left hand side when we look
through this sample imaged at a pixel
size of about 60 NM or so for a ceramic
bead it's not particularly spherical but
we can see all of this internal detail
which we can then analyze as well
something we were particularly
interested in when performing
nanotomography was are we able to
resolve all of the finest features
Within These materials so by Imaging the
same sample at various pixel sizes or
equivalent to resolutions we could then
see what we were were getting out from
our images so that Central image of the
cellulose spead which you can see these
large uh spherical pores within that
sample however there's lots of white
space or material phase between them and
we knew that in reality there's a lot
more porosity in these structures than
just from those spherical pores so with
the high resolution scan it's about a 15
to 30 nanm pixel size we can see those
larger spherical pores and also the the
pore structure in between them as well
suggesting to us that now we can start
to see those individual
features the images to the top right of
those is from focused iron beam uh again
we was able to get very high
resolutions and it's the same type of
structure as you can see on the ceramic
bead on the left hand side and at the
time these were cons called gel in and
shell and you can really see that
characteristic shell going around these
materials the whole way around for the
X-ray image on the left hand side and on
the top right just across the bottom
when we're really zooming into an area
of
Interest now I'm not going to go into
too much uh detail about all of this
characterization that we did in this
paper but suffice to say we did a lot of
analysis to see what was the correct um
pixel size or resolution that was
required to perform uh sufficient
quality Imaging of these samples what we
found is that uh once we got down to a
pixel size of about 30 nanometers or so
we were resolving the vast majority of
the chromatography bead in each case and
pushing it further just caused more
complications without too much benefit
so when you're performing high
resolution imaging what you really need
to do is get the right resolution for
the sample that you're looking at any if
you have a a worse resolution you don't
get all of the information you have a a
resolution that's better than what you
need ultimately you're you're making
lots of compromises in other
areas so from that data we are able to
look at what a column looks like and
also what uh an individual
chromatography bead looks like which
gave us a huge amount of information
however in those studies we were looking
at entirely clean samples and we were
very interested in how do these
materials behave and how do they change
as a function of being used on the left
hand side we have a study where we were
looking at uh how the packed bed
actually compresses because the resins
that we're using in bioprocessing are
extremely expensive and they're not
always is made out of the strongest
materials so if you then push them too
hard then what happens is you start to
compress the bed therefore change the
flow pass available to your mobile phase
and in the worst case scenarios as can
be seen in in the central image you
could actually irreversibly compress
your column which which ruins it you
have to throw it away so and you're
spending a lot of money in replacing
that so we all want to avoid that but at
the same time we want to run our systems
as hard as possible to get the most out
of them and so in that on the left hand
side the top in top left corner we have
an image of the entrance of a
chromatography column A cellulose based
Matrix before use and then after use and
and what you can see there is that the
column after use has been compressed and
change shaped quite a lot compared to
before use where the black space uh
flanking either side is the plastic
molding that this column is is contained
within and so we could not only
visualize the compression but then also
measure it and the most simple way to do
that was to again look at the inter Beed
parity now in the bottom left we've got
a lot of bars um and so the two sets on
the left hand side are for a sample that
is run at a flow rate which is
recommended by the vendor and on the
right hand side the two sets of bars are
for a flow rate well beyond what you
would typically use and so what we could
and then the the sets are split into the
edge and the center again we were able
to differentiate that proy in all cases
what we can see that essentially if you
run the column at the recommended flow
rates you weren't getting any uh
compression that we could either
visualize or measure however when you
when you run it far too hard you can see
with that blue bar on the right hand
side that decreasing inpe paracity both
at the edge and the center of the column
suggesting that the the space between
the beads is being reduced thereby your
flow paths are changing in your
chromatography column before some
reversion in the red
bar now whilst we were just looking at a
sample that didn't include B Logics in
this case we um we did really need to
consider that inside the chromatography
be as you start to use them and you get
a new accumulation of
fance uh you also get a chance to the
diffusive characteristics within your
chromatography beads and whil we
struggle to image these it at sufficient
quality what we were able to do is use
an erosion dilation approach whereby
we'd image a clean chromatography bead
and then we'd artificially change its
paracity or the pore size whilst
maintaining the original geometry
this allowed us to uh assimilate for uh
the accumulation of fallons on the
surface and also inside the
cromatography bead structures without
actually having to image them in the
first place and this also allowed us to
normalize our structures for prosty so
we could begin to compare samples that
did have different characteristics if we
could then normalize between them and
this is very powerful and Lead it led us
on to some of the work that I'll speak
about
later another study uh that we
collaborated with IIT Delhi Professor
anor's group was can we correlate what
images look like in terms of our
materials as they start to get used and
fouled with their conventional
bioprocess metrics such as their yield
and the Purity and the quality of the
product that you're getting out at the
end so on the right hand side we have a
couple of images where we've got a clean
chromatography resin on the surface and
on the right hand the very right hand
side image we start to get these cluns
and this accumulation of f which is
blocking the entrance for your product
to get into your actual purification uh
material and then we started to look at
comparing this to the number of Cycles
they go through with what they the
chromatography beads and columns
actually start to look at so we're
getting a far greater picture of not
only what do these materials uh look
like but how do they behave when we
start to actually use them and push them
to their limits at both chromatography
column and individual bead
scales so Downstream bioprocessing isn't
just limited to chromatography and so we
are very interested in looking at other
units operations and something we
started off with is depth filtration and
this start happens at the very start of
a downstream bio process where you're
just clarifying and harvesting your
material from a bio reactor so the the
product and the process stream that goes
through these materials is uh far more
complicated and much more of a dirty
feed compared to what you'd be putting
through a chromatography
coln something that's very interesting
to us as I said at the start of the uh
presentation was looking across multiple
length scales so on the left hand side
we could image a whole a whole depth
filter without having to cut it open we
could then see inside it and what does a
layer of depth filter look like and then
go down another length scale again to
look at what do the pores look like on
the very left hand side uh Within These
depth filter
matrices in a very similar vein to what
we saw with inside the chromatography
beads getting the right pixel size and
therefore resolution is absolutely uh
necessary in order to get the most out
of our image data sets so in the center
we've got an image inside of a depth
filter exactly the same sample looked at
across different machines and different
pixel sizes and as we go from left to
right um I'm not sure how clear it'll be
on the screen but you can the quality
that we were getting out of our data
sets was much improved uh in terms of
what we could see but also what we could
then measure on the right hand side we
started to get values that were far more
representative of the this the
orthogonal measurements that we were
making in terms of the parity
Etc Dev filters are also asymmetric so
they change as a function of distance
through the material and so on the
bottom we what we started to do is look
at what are the size of those poles so
on the downstream layer on the left hand
side of that uh that red image we start
to see these larger vacuous spaces
within these structures um and then as
we as we move to towards the exit of the
material it then gets far tighter which
is spe and it's specifically designed to
do that and then this the series of
yellow streamlines you'll be able to see
is some flow simulation work that we
performed and something that's
particularly interesting to look at now
is actual individual particles rather
than just the bulk because now that
we're starting to look at much larger
products such as leny and a and a and
all these things being much larger than
M antibodies we really have to start
thinking about their size and taking
that into
account a paper that we published last
year um that came out of the danam brace
World group also continued this work
looking at a series of different depth
filters and how they change as a
function of um life cycle usage and
again we were able to apply x-ray CT on
clean filters at the top and then on
used filters at the bottom where they
got where they're really filled with all
of these biological materials and again
that was an important part of that paper
in terms of characterizing How does the
structure relate to function and
performance something that was also very
interesting about dep filtration is that
the material that you use isn't normally
just a Poe phase and a material phase is
the there's actually multiple materials
of construction so you may have a
cellulose base Matrix which is what we
had here you may have perlite and you
may also have Diet to Surf which we
didn't have in this case but on the left
hand side we've got this detailed 2D
image and then a 3D image next to it
whereby you've got this black space
which is the pores you've then got this
this dark gray Mater aterial which is
the cellulose Matrix and then this
brighter white material which is the
perlite in this case and what we're able
to do by applying triple phase
tomography is then separate these three
phases out uh and so you can see the
blue cellulos Matrix and the orange
representing the perite in this case on
the right hand side and this allowed us
to get far more information out of our
3D data sets than if we were just
looking at material and void
phe something that we we're also very
interested in is sterilizing grade
filtration which happens at the end of
your process whereby uh you don't want
to spend all of that time money and
resource on producing and purifying a
product to then lose a lot of it at the
end of your process where sterilizing
grade filtration takes place and whilst
for maps this wasn't too much of an
issue as we start to look at these
bigger products and in this case we
looked at liposomes they get closer to
the poe size that we're expecting these
materials presenting various
challenges again on the left hand side
what we're able to do is adhere a small
piece of membrane on top of a pin head
and then scan through it and we're
particularly interested in a dual layer
system whereby it had an an upstream
layer and a downstream layer the
Upstream layer represented by the
central images is asymmetric so the porw
size reduces as you get closer to the
exit of the material and by applying a
poor Network map we were able to then
represent the size of these pores in
this case red being larger so we can see
their size their shape and also how they
connect with the rest of the
structure to the right of that we then
had a symmetric membrane which means
that the structure is considered to be
cons consistent throughout the material
and again we can see that by the porw
size being very consistent um compared
to the asymmetric
material by having these visualizations
of these Poe Network Maps we could also
then produce size distributions on the
right hand side I'm not going to go
through too much of the detail but
suffice to say we can not only see this
asymmetry or symmetry in both cases but
also uh then quantify this as a function
of distance through the
sample however as I said earlier one of
the real challenges with xray C is
Imaging biological materials within
these samples at uh very high
resolutions and so therefore we use
confocal microscopy so we dyed some
liposomes and also bacteria we flowed
them through through the structure of
these membranes and then after
filtration we looked under the confocal
microscope where liposomes were retained
so on the left hand side we can see that
we're getting a band right next to the
surface of each sample for both
cases what we're able to do with this
information then is look at how this
impacts the operation conditions which
for liposome ster filtration are a
little bit different to what you'd
expect for conventional monoclonal
antibodies we saw that as we increased
the differential pressure in this case
we got improved performance both in
terms of our transmission but also our
throughput uh whilst for maps you may
expect there to be Fon build up and
maybe the opposite to happen what we
could then do is then image a series of
membranes after filtration at different
uh differential pressures and then see
how their performance compares to the
retention profile and we saw that as you
increase differential pressure not only
do you get that Improvement in
performance but you also get a much
sharper retention band uh get that gets
closer to the entrance of the sterile
filter whilst we're still working on
this uh problem at the moment uh we
suspect that there can be some
absorption mechanics going on whereby a
longer residance time at a uh lower
differential pressure results in uh a
greater amount of time for liposomes to
absorb and so whilst we uh were
interested to see that the performance
improved as we increase differential
pressure we're also concerned that you
can you risk the chance of bacteria
cenet rating with these materials
because you want to push these systems
as hard as you can but if you're getting
bacteria going going through as well
then you're really defeating the purpose
and so at one of these diff differential
pressures we image uh we filter just
liposomes and then liposomes with beIN
bacteria which pose a particular
challenge because they're very small and
very good at getting through things what
we can see for the Upstream membrane on
the right hand side is that there is a
different retention profile between
these two systems and so as I said
whilst we're still working on this we
could see that there is an interaction
uh happening as a result of filtration
of lots of bacteria in these systems and
it's something we need really need to
make sure that we get on top of if we're
going to get high yields and high
quality products for these new
systems so we can now image visualize
and characterize a wide range of
different Downstream bioprocessing
materials and in 2021 this led us to uh
apply for and also get accepted
Fellowship Grant whereby we'd use all of
that information in order to inform the
design of new materials this would
include looking at existing structures
for example the chromatography resonance
and filters we've been talking about but
something we thought was very
interesting was that we've been already
doing 3D imaging and flow analysis if we
could then couple this with 3D design
and also 3D printing we could exactly
specify what we want we could fabricate
it to a high standard and then we could
take it through this design cycle to see
if it's behaving as we would
expect and in a collaboration with uh Dr
Sone de Martino the University of
Edinburgh uh we were able to look at
some of the samples that his lab is
producing in terms of 3D structures
andalus to chromatography materials
across multiple length scales so what
we're able to do is specifically tailor
and specify the size of the structures
we wanted to look at so if we look at
the top uh series of images we've got a
2d cut through
of the cad design starting on a very
coarse structure both of the material
and the POR phase on the left hand side
as we move over to the right hand side
this 200 micrometer feature size is far
finer so the both the pores and the
material is much smaller in both case
but they still got the same sort of
geometry now there's a lot of cfd and
simulation work that's been performed on
theoretical models to show what's the
best you could do uh in theory however
what we wanted to do is test are we
actually printing these samples to
specification and are there any things
that we can help with by applying x-ray
CT and on the bottom hat uh row you can
see three images of the same types of
structures but when we've actually
printed them in the lab and then imaged
them using x-ray CT and even though we
get very good agreement between these
images we still started to see some
artifacts and other things that we could
improve in the printing process to
improve the Fidelity of the structures
we're designing and also then produc
it on the right hand side I'm playing a
couple of videos just to show you a
rotation in that sample where you can
see all of that detailed structure both
for the poe phase and the material phase
for the core structure which is rotating
and now the medium structure on the
right hand side again we get lots of
this intricate um internal detail by
using x-ray CT without actually having
to cut open the sample so it's actually
closer to we originally
intended so that's very similar to the
pack B scale and then we wanted to move
down a length scale to look at what does
an individual chromatography bead look
like in terms of a single unit in this
case on the left hand side we've got an
image of one of those individual units
we can then binarize it into material
and voidage phase and then compare it to
the cad file which is the third blue
image and whil the the cad file isn't
filled in when you when you print it
obviously you do actually uh produce it
we can then start to Overlay these and
see are we printing exactly what we're
designing and we could examine every
single element in every single position
within our 3D printed structures we've
been taking this through the design
cycle to iteratively improve the design
and printing process for these materials
which we recently submitted for
publication we could then also perform
flow analysis not just on the the
theoretical CAD design but also on the
real structures that we'd analyzed both
the bulk fluid in the permeable domain
in this case and also looking at
individual particles in red and again as
I said very important to start to think
about particles now that we're getting
much larger products going through these
structures now I've been talking about
hundreds of micrometers which is closer
to the pack bed scale rather than
anything that you'd see inside of a
chromatography bead however all of these
materials have an internal proy that's
been designed in whereby we can then
improve greatly enhance our surface area
to volume ratio for binding purposes
which is very similar to what you see
inside of one of these chromatography
beads in a very similar manner to how I
described earlier on the left hand side
we have a small piece of the 3D printed
structure next with you've got the
interface between the pin head and the
adherence with then x-ray CT above that
whereby we can get these 2D and 3D
representations of the inter internal
structure of all materials that we
looked
at and in a very similar vein to what we
saw before we can perform simulation
work on this in the diffusive domain
both for the bulk on the left hand side
next to it for individual partic uh
streamlines is represented by the red
lines and again we can start to look at
the pow size we can see how they all
interconnect with each other and then
produce a size distribution this then
allows us to not only tailor and design
some of the characteristics when we're
designing and printing at the analogous
to the column scale but also what is the
right po size distribution for our
product and process inside of our
material phase as well we can really
start to noriz across multiple length
scales to get the most out of these
structures so to conclude 3D design and
printing uh is a very powerful technique
um to start to look at new bioprocessing
structures and it's very much powered by
3D imaging in terms of better
understanding the design and how it
relates to structure function and
performance we can do this not only for
these 3D printed structures but also for
the uh existing residance and
filters I got some file fin references
that you may want to look at later and
finally just to thank my collaborators
and sponsors at pool Corporation friends
and colleagues at UCL biochemical and
chemical engineering the University of
Edinburgh and also Fujifilm my email is
on the bottom right thank you very
much